if you find something that's going to
hit the earth deflecting it is actually
relatively easy because if you find it
many years before it hits the earth say
1020 years before it hits the earth
remember the earth is going to go around
the Sun 10 or 20 times as well that
object so these things have a long ways
to travel before they hit and that means
a tiny tiny tiny change in their in
their orbit will keep it something from
hitting the earth you just slow the
earth down a little bit yes is a great
new Chinese gonna be coming out about
this but for those of you who took
physics we all jump at the same time we
don't change the velocity of the earth
because we're connected to it right you
need an external momentum so what you
act or answer
yeah the boring answer is to change the
orbits of the asteroid by a tiny amount
and one of the things that we had been
urging since the foundation of our the
b612 foundation is that we human beings
ought to test that technology because we
know how to do it and in fact NASA is
now we're going to do that test it's
called the dart mission again about 2022
I believe it is we're just going to
actually run a small spacecraft into an
asteroid and then it's actually
sufficient in mass majority of cases to
keep an asteroid from hitting the earth
provided you have notice now right now I
don't want to go back no back to your
question the you know predicting that
something is going to hit requires you
can't be able to calculate you know
orbits very very accurately and know the
uncertainties in order to calculate you
know what are the chances that this
thing hits and I don't want to give the
impression that we're the only ones
doing there are other people that think
of you know they calculate these things
they put these things in big tables okay
but think of what the difference is
between Google Maps and if somebody
listed for you every restaurant in New
York City in a big table what's the
difference and why is why was Google
Maps so important to commerce due to
things like lyft and uber they all
started by using Google Maps Yelp Airbnb
because they didn't the the visual
mapping part the underlying machinery
was built for them and they could just
build on top of it and so what we want
to do is allow people to build
navigation tools for the solar system
without having to do all the heavy
lifting
99.99% of the calculation is exactly the
same it can happen in the background and
so we want to provide that as a service
[Music]